at this altitude I can this episode is
brought to you by 99designs 99designs
is the global creative platform that
makes it easy for designers and clients
to work together from logos to apps and
packaging to books 99designs is the
go-to design resource for any budget
I've used 99 designs for many many years
now I've used them for book covers for
instance mock-ups for the 4-hour body
which went on to become a number one New
York Times bestseller illustrations for
my multi-volume The Tao of Seneca and
other graphic design projects and I've
been really impressed by the quality of
their designers and the designs that
I've ended up using most recently I used
99 designs to update the illustrations
and layouts of my five morning rituals
eBook this covers my most consistent
morning routines and rituals and I offer
that as an incentive for people to sign
up for my newsletter so this is a PDF
bonus that acts as a carrot to increase
the number of email subscribers the
illustrations inside are gorgeous and I
loved working with the designer who we
selected for the project so you can
check it out take a look at that at 99
designs comm forward slash Tim that's
the number 99 designs com forward slash
Tim and you can see exactly what I'm
talking about with a real world example
of what has come out of work with them
99 designs
designer search tool connects you
directly with one designer based on a
design category or an industry
specialization style skill level
availability and more so you can really
check all the boxes that you need and
see who matches up or you can start a
contest and that means you invite the
entire community to take a shot at your
project then you pick your favorite
right now you guys my listeners that is
can receive a free $99
great on your first design contest so
check it out to see what it looks like
to get your first free upgrade please
visit 99designs comm for massage tim and
click on the link in the landing page so
again check it out 99designs dot-com
forward slash tim this episode is
brought to you by LegalZoom which more
than 2 million americans have used to
help start their businesses past guests
even such as well wordpress lead
developer CEO of automatic matt
mullenweg
now valued at more than a billion
dollars have used LegalZoom to help with
their business needs specifically in his
case to form his company but LegalZoom
isn't just for launching your business
their services include everything from
helping you to manage changing tax laws
reviewing contracts creating NDA's
non-disclosure agreements
important stuff handling lease
agreements and assisting with really any
other legal challenge hurdle
inconvenience that typically takes time
and effort away from running your
business the best part is that you won't
get charged by the hour
because LegalZoom isn't a law firm so
they won't be running the clock up and
spinning circles just to raise your bill
instead they just ask you to pay one low
upfront price for whatever it is that
you're looking to get all a cart style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T I am at checkout
capital T lower case I am again take a
peek legalzoom.com and enter promo code
to him
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
today's episode features Peter Mallick
Peter is the president of creative
planning one of the largest independent
wealth management firms in the United
States creative planning provides wealth
management services to clients manages
more than 36 billion dollars for clients
in all 50 states and abroad and has been
featured as the number one independent
wealth management firm in America by
Barron's I was 2017 Peter is also
featured on Worth's magazines Power 100
featuring the most powerful men and
women in global finance the only
financial planner on that list in both
2017 and 2018 creative planning was also
featured in Forbes in 2016 as the
number-one RIAA for growth over the last
10 years he is the co-author of
unshakable alongside Tony Robbins and
that is how the introduction was
initially made and will talk I'm sure
more about that Peter welcome to the
show
thanks for having me Tim I wanted to
have you on the show because we've had a
number of conversations and in full
disclosure so people know the playing
field I am not currently a client but
I'm in a position that we have had a
number of conversations about money
management and I found a lot of your
observations to be thought-provoking and
in some cases very counterintuitive and
I had read money mastered the game which
is how I initially interviewed Tony and
for those who are interested my very
first Instagram photo ever was of Tony
Paul my entire face which was taken
after that interview and then
unshakeable was published and your your
name kept on coming up and you do manage
money for a number of my friends but we
do not have any type of financial
relationship which i think is important
for me to to make clear upfront I do
find your thinking very interesting and
this is a world meaning finance and
personal finance that can be very
intimidating not only for people
who
are trying to find their way in terms of
asset allocation and looking towards
retirement but really for for myself for
friends of mine who would like to think
of themselves as competent in other
areas or some other areas
this can be overwhelmingly or seem
overwhelmingly complex so I thought we
might start if it's okay with you and we
can steer this in any direction we want
to go but with a couple of very specific
asset classes or potential investments
and how you think about them because
this might be a way to at least get into
your thought process and the first thing
that I have on this list is gold I do
not currently own any gold what are your
thoughts on gold well I don't own any
either and it's a great way to start
because it's one of those hot-button
issues that half your listeners are
going gonna decide how they feel about
me based on this answer alone I think
gold and Bitcoin are the are definitely
hot-button topics so the short the the
punchline is I'm not a fan of gold but
here's the reasoning why so if you think
about investing if you look at the great
investors of history I think the one all
your listeners would be familiar with
this is Warren Buffett right what they
want is they want something that pays
them or if you buy a building you want
to collect rent if you buy a bond you
want it you want to get the the yield
from that bond if you buy a stock you
want you want the dividend or at some
point you want to benefit from the
earnings of that company even if it
doesn't give provide a dividend Gold
doesn't provide any income and the value
of gold is that someone else will pay
you more for it later it means that is
that kind of straightforward so there's
a very speculative element to it if we
look at gold going all the way back to
the Great Depression to today it's
performed worse than every major asset
class except cash which if you want to
call cash an asset class so you could
have done better in the US or
international or emerging markets or
with bonds and been collecting income
all along the way now not only did it
perform worse than all those asset
classes it was more volatile than those
asset classes so you're taking all this
volatility risk
and you're not getting the reward it we
don't have to go all the way back to the
Great Depression if you look at the last
ten years
same story one of the worst performers
but you're getting all of the volatility
and you're not getting any income and
then if your start to look at the tax
consequences you pay a higher tax on the
gains in gold so you mean if you have
some modest gain to show for dealing
with all the volatility and getting no
income and hoping somebody will pay you
more for it later when all that happens
you're gonna pay higher taxes than if
you had just bought you know Apple stock
or some other stock thank you so if you
had to take the not strummin position
but steel man position meaning the
strongest counter-argument what do smart
people or otherwise smart people pending
on how you interpret their position on
gold argue the ownership for the
ownership of gold what would the what
would the most compelling even if you
don't find it personally compelling but
of the arguments for gold what yeah what
is the most compelling I think when you
see the smart people who are really
broke old they their main argument tends
to be the economic system is a house of
cards or fraud a fraudulent system or a
manipulated system and I don't think
it's a house of cards I don't think it's
a fraudulent system but I agree it's
manipulated I mean that the Federal
Reserve exists to help manipulate the
economy that that's why it's there so
I'm always fascinated with conspiracy
theories say oh the Federal Reserve's
manipulating the economy that's that's
their whole job is to is to control
inflation and to keep unemployment low
and to do so by trying to manipulate the
economy but I think that's the strongest
argument is that the country has an
enormous amount of debt the same thing
is happening across all developed
countries most developed countries have
a lot of debt
someday that debts gonna have to be paid
that we're gonna have extremely high
inflation currencies going to be
worthless and people will be using gold
as the store of value and as currency
and you know let's just say I mean that
is the case you have to just draw that
to the logical conclusion right so now
I'm going to walk out of my front door
and I'm gonna go down to the local
McDonald's or Kwik Trip and I'm going to
pull out
my gold and I'm going to buy I mean go
to the grocery store with that I'm gonna
I'm gonna go to the gas station with
that what's going to happen I remember
being in Oklahoma seeing some
prospective clients and we were talking
about this scenario and he said I said
now what do you think is gonna happen if
the whole economic system has collapsed
yo stocks are worthless bonds are
worthless the dollars worthless and
we're dealing with gold and he goes well
I've got my plan right there and he was
pointing across the room at his gun rack
and that that's basically the world we
would be living and I don't think we'd
be too worried about what our currency
isn't but I would tell you that the the
people making the case against me would
consider that to be naive got it yeah it
is very difficult to shave off a small
fragment of gold to buy your six pack at
7-eleven the you may be better off like
you said getting stockpiling guns
cigarettes and tampons and other things
that you might be able to trade if
that's the thesis but exactly it's a
gold I don't take us too far down the
gold rabbit hole Bitcoin you mentioned
Bitcoin might as well talk about that
yeah I figure that's a good place to
start and I know some of you the friends
we have in your friends that we have in
common are very big proponents of this
and so they also I should say just just
as a side note there they also have
tremendous informational advantage when
a group that's true I think if you
Bitcoin is interesting because I it gets
muddled with other things so first we
have blockchain technology which backs
it up and a lot has been written about
this there are some very big real
companies like IBM and Accenture
investing in this Walmart at using using
it for inventory tracking that
technology is real so what but what you
hear people say is oh the you know
blockchain is a real thing and you're an
idiot if you don't like Bitcoin well I
mean the TV is a real thing you know I'm
glad it's invented but that doesn't mean
everything that comes out of it is going
to work right it did that doesn't mean
that every product that comes out of
it's going to work so blockchain is just
the technology that allows crypto
currencies
to work now there are several thousand
crypto currencies and bitcoin is one of
them and even the people that are really
into cryptocurrencies as part of the
future many of them will acknowledge
that bitcoin is not the one that
probably has the best profile to be the
winner going forward but nonetheless it
has a very big following it was the
first one to utilize blockchain
technology I believe and clearly that
the first can a breakout one but there's
a difference between the you know the
cutting edge and the bleeding edge I
mean you you have Apple today you have
the iPhone today but before Apple and
the iPhone
there was black Berrien and palm you
know those were you know bleeding edge
they came out they were wonderful things
that someone could have said this
technology is amazing you know you're an
idiot if you think palm and or
BlackBerry's not going to rule the world
but someone else took the concept and
made it better before Google there was
excite in AOL and Lycos you know someone
else came along and improved upon the
technology and made it better and I
think that's what we're gonna see here
blockchain technology that's the real
thing that's gonna change the way the
world works much the way you know the
internet did and I think we're gonna
move from centralized databases to not
to decentralized databases and I think
probably some cryptocurrency of these
2000 and however many other hundreds or
thousands there's gonna be in the future
probably a one or maybe a few of them
will wind up being used but the odds it
is going to be Bitcoin is very very low
and so I any investment in Bitcoin is to
me purely speculative again there's no
income coming from we're just betting
that someone else is gonna pay more for
it later and that this is going to be
the cryptocurrency or one of the crypto
currencies
that's that prevails and I think that's
not an investment it doesn't mean
someone can't buy it but it has much
more speculative element to me than you
know being part of an investor's
portfolio that's where you anticipate in
the future the investment having worked
out mm-hmm if I look at people who have
made a lot of money investing or in some
cases spec it
but let's just for the for the moment
assume that they're playing more a
single deck game blackjack where they
can actually apply a system of some type
right they're not they're not entirely
playing roulette and those those people
in my experience generally have had
advantages whether those are
informational analytical behavioral they
have some type of advantage that allows
them an unfair competitive edge to some
extent so it could be that they know the
creators of say in the case of
cryptocurrencies different
cryptocurrencies
it could be that say like a John Arnold
they just have an incredible domain
expertise and level of access that
allows them to work with say energy and
you can go down the line and find people
in almost any sector that have these
advantages in the world in which you
play in creative planning or personally
we can make it personally what what do
you feel your superpowers are or you or
your differentiators what are your
advantages or systems that allow you to
approach things differently I think
there are no superpowers and I think no
one has I think any more really public
market investing superpowers I think you
can go out of the public markets and you
can develop a very big competitive
advantages as someone who's involved in
investment so for example I do think
that someone buying private real estate
can be better at that than someone else
who's buying private real estate and I
think substantially so I think when you
get in the public markets I'll tell you
how I feel about you know investing in
general and then what I think mean we
would do that we would think would add
value and make us different and I think
is are the reasons for our success I
think when you look at the public
markets you were talking about people
having special knowledge and insight
knowledge and the thing about the stock
market is that that doesn't exist with
the stock market right so when you're
talking about the stock market in the
bond market there is nobody that has
that in
cider knowledge I mean some people have
it but if they use it it's called
insider trading and you can go to jail
for that and so you know the advice
would be not to do that so the kid in
his garage in Malaysia has the same
information as the top analyst at
Goldman Sachs because all the
information is public right so that
we're all sharing this information and
the markets become incredibly efficient
especially once we got in a high-speed
Internet right once everyone started to
get information at the same time there
used to be a time where you know some
people were outperforming the market and
someone uncovered it was because they
were getting issues of money magazine or
value line before they came out they
were seeing him at the printing press or
when they were being delivered to the
magazine stand even that doesn't exist
anymore we're all getting the
information in real time and so if you
think about a company like McDonald's
you'll hear on TV on on with the
financial media when when the market
goes down they'll do everyone's selling
there's never a time where everyone's
selling for every seller there's a buyer
right so if McDonald's has 30 million
people sell the stock today that means
30 million people bought it and there
are really really bright people on both
sides of that trade and there are really
really really stupid people on both
sides of that trade and they're all
sharing the same information and that's
collective wisdom eventually gets the
price where it's supposed to be and now
might there be somebody who can beat
this system I mean the statistics say
that's very very difficult that means
more than 85% of people trading these
large stocks which make up the huge
majority of the market that are
professionals underperform the index
over long periods of time which means
underperforming somebody just buying the
500 stocks and literally doing nothing
if you do that you're beating the
overwhelming majority the professionals
because by the time you pay the taxes
and the transaction costs and you make
all the behavioral mistakes human beings
are gonna make you're probably gonna
you're gonna have that drag that
friction that causes underperformance
and so I think it's this is a space
where a lot of successful people and you
interview the most successful people
they are you're interviewing LeBron
LeBrons telling you why he's better than
everybody else and your part of it is it
starts out a physical but it is
certainly that's in the very small
minority of it 90% of it is what he's
doing to make it happen so very
successful people then go to the public
markets and go well clearly there must
be people that are better that this then
than others clearly I could find this
guy that can trade and beat the market
and that's really just not the case so
we do to try to you know improve upon
things is people have a lot of fear when
it comes to investing I think it starts
when you're very very young
some people have a fear of losing their
money or you know some people think they
understand certain things but they don't
understand markets so they have a fear
of investing altogether some people
spend all their money at one thing I've
noticed from this profession is very
very few people have a very healthy
attitude about money you know that it's
okay to earn it and there's a smart way
to save it and invest it and it's okay
to spend it it's okay to feel good with
it not spent too much not spend too
little even when you look at the
financial gurus some of them are telling
people don't go to Starbucks in the
morning that's that's a waste of money
that you know that's silly so what we
try to do is we try to make sure that we
can keep people engaged in the portfolio
so they hit their goals so let's take
the stock market for an example if
somebody you know one of your listeners
invests today the odds of the markets
gonna be positive a year from now is
about 75% just positive three out of
four years which means one out of four
years it's it's not positive but if we
look at the market over five years it's
positive well over ninety percent of the
time in over ten years it's positive
more than 98% of the time so what the
longer we can stretch this out the more
probable a certain outcome is so if you
have somebody who has short-term needs
they shouldn't be in the market because
no matter how good we are
someone can fly into a building and
everything changes tomorrow and the
stocks are going to go down it doesn't
matter how good our analysis is anything
you're going to need you know one year
three or five four years from now those
should be in things like bonds where we
expect a lower return but we have a high
probability that money's going to be
there for us and the longer term would
be stocks in the very low
terr might be alternative investments
and to do that you really have to know a
person and what's their tax bracket and
what state do they live in and and do
they have outside income sources like
Social Security or a pension or rental
income and how much fluctuation can they
handle and when you know all of those
things and how much money they need and
when they need it you can start to match
the asset classes to their needs and
then they're more likely to stay on that
roller coaster and the roller-coaster
works out great and everyone will have a
good time unless you try to get off of
it in the middle of the ride and so I
think if you've got a process to match
people's investments to their needs
you're more likely to have a good
outcome because most people they screw
things up themselves like if you take
someone who invested before 2008 you'll
hear a lot of people go I'm not going to
invest because I lost my money all my
money there then those of us that are
older have friends that say they'll
never invest because they lost
everything in the tech bubble or after
9/11 well if you're a long-term investor
and you were diversified is basically
impossible to have last lost money if
you put all your money in your the worst
investor of the last 90 years and you
put all of your money into the market
the day before the Oh 809 crash today
you've more than doubled your money I
mean the S&P 500 is more than doubled
since then we can do that the day before
9/11 the day before the tech bubble you
you have to go out of your way to have
lost money but people find a way to do
it by making behavioral mistakes or
working with advisers that make the
behavioral mistakes on their behalf so
let me dig into a couple of questions
related to to what you just said and
maybe as a baseline and you could help
me do this also but there are there are
different reasons for our motivations
for participating in markets right yep
you could you could you could aim to get
rich using the markets in other words
you could be aiming to be a Paul Tudor
Jones or someone like that where you
come in with a handful of dollars and
that is how you make your fortune in the
same way that someone might make their
fortune building a tech startup to exit
or IPO for instance the second would be
staying say preserving wealth using the
markets in some
passion right and then you might have in
third place or not in third place but
third option being becoming
incrementally richer using markets but
not counting on it for that bulk of your
principle right so the the way you
approach things would seem to depend
very heavily on which which category you
you fall in but to come back to and I'm
just talking through also to clarify my
own thinking on some of this how how
would you then if if you have an it if
it's it's if it's how do you assess
let's just say someone's considering
creative planning and then firm acts
firm why firms II right how do you if if
the argument can be made that you have
to assess over the very long term
how can one separate the good the bad
the ugly and the excellent in terms of
wealth management over a shorter time
horizon does that does that make sense
because because one might be inclined to
say are and I'm gonna take my my hundred
units of capital split it into 20 units
and give it to five different wealth
managers and see how they do over a
three-year period of time or whatever
the period of time might be and then
assess but if each each of those wealth
managers is saying you have to actually
stick with with us for the long term
then you end up in a bit of a pickle
from a decision-making standpoint so how
should the investor think about that
scenario well I think I would start with
just defining money manager versus a
wealth manager so let's say that let's
say that somebody is they believe that
they can beat the market by stock
picking or market timing so market
timing being you put your money in the
market you think it's gonna go down you
take it out you put it back in or you
you want somebody who's gonna trade
stocks and try to beat the market that
would be a money manager you might say
okay I'm going to go higher
you know money manager a to buy my large
cap value stocks and money manager B
by my bonds and money means receipted by
my international small stocks and you
might have them all managed in the same
space and compare them and to do this
you have to believe that these managers
are going to add value by after fees and
taxes trading stocks in a way where they
beat their respective benchmarks now in
the alternate world of wealth managers
wealth managers really sitting with a
client and looking out at the universe
of money managers and deciding with the
client okay where are we gonna put our
stocks where are we gonna put our bonds
where are we gonna put our international
stocks and so the wealth manager is
helping with all of the portfolio
allocation they might manage all of it
in house they might outsource it and
they might also give advice on other
things whether its tax or insurance or
risk MANET whatever that they'll they'll
look at a bigger piece and that's more
of what a wealth manager would do within
those worlds you have a very big debate
between passive management and active
management so active management would be
you know Paul Tudor Jones hedge fund
managers mutual fund managers separately
managed account managers where you're
paying somebody to try to beat a
respective index so an international
manager would be trying to beat the
international index a large cap US
manager would be trying to beat this and
P 500 index which is just you know 500
the biggest companies in the in the
country I think that what you're seeing
in the marketplace is more and more
money is moving too from active managers
to passive managers meaning instead of
trying to hire somebody to beat the S&P
500 I'm going to buy the S&P 500 and
that question doesn't become which
manager am I gonna pick to trade these
it becomes which wealth manager am I
gonna hire to help me determine how much
should be in large cap US stocks in the
first place versus international stocks
versus bonds versus real estate and so
we would be in the group where where
wealth managers looking at everything we
don't believe that if we we pay somebody
to trade stocks they're gonna do better
than the S&P 500 so we're gonna buy the
index there and we're gonna buy it in
several other spaces and we're gonna
pick our battles on where we think we
can create out performance or what the
industry calls alpha and we would look
at alternative investments for that we
think you can you
do that in private markets where
everybody doesn't have the same
information and where if we look at a
management team and their education
their credentials and their experience
we feel we can extrapolate that they
might actually be better than another
team so if you look at alternative asset
classes would be things like private
equity private lending private real
estate things that fall into categories
like that I think are where we would try
to get that our alpha for the clients
gotcha so let's talk about the
alternative then for it for a second in
the alternative investments what's what
are the alternative options that the
where you like to go fishing or at least
exploring is it a short list is it a
real estate investment trusts private
equity master limited partnerships what
type of alternative options do you feel
are most viable so I'll start by
defining it for your audience because
it's a question I get a lot and I always
correlate it to public markets so you
can buy a publicly traded stock which
would be like Nike or Google you can
lend money to corporation or a
government that would be a bond if you
loan money the federal government it's a
Treasury if you loan it to a county or a
state it's a municipal bond if you loan
it to a strong corporation it's a
corporate bond if you loan it to one
that's not doing so great it's a
high-yield bond or a junk bond and of
course there's publicly traded real
estate you know so someone can go online
open a custodial account at a place like
TD Ameritrade Schwab or fidelity and
type in a couple things and five minutes
later own a portfolio of all those
things each of those things has a
private alternative meaning they're not
trading on the public markets and they
follow a different set of rules they're
less regulated you usually have to be an
accredited investor with a million or
more to be able to access those some of
them require that you're a qualified
purchaser with five million or more to
get into them but instead of publicly
traded stock you could invest in private
equity so there might be a fund that one
fund we use bought Dunkin Donuts and
then took a national and
sold it and that was one of dozens of
companies they owned so that's what
private equity does the private lending
lends money to businesses private
businesses that are growing and then
there's private real estate where you
know have somebody raising money and
buying apartment complexes or commercial
buildings all over the place and
alternative investments the advantage is
we do expect you'll probably do better
than the public version of that
investment and part of its the
illiquidity premium meaning the money is
tied up for a while so if you go put
your money in a private real estate fund
you can't just exit the next day because
the gal you gave the money to is running
around buying buildings she can't sell a
building because you feel like taking
the money out and going on vacation same
thing when you go into private equity or
private lending you're making a
commitment to give these funds your
money for five years ten years or more
so they can go buy all these businesses
or buy all these properties and then
sell them all and then the fund closes
those are the most common alternative
investments and we do think they're you
know the the type of company that's
running those and they're experienced we
think that matters and we think that
gives an edge from a performance
perspective now basically anything
that's not publicly traded is an
alternative investment so if you one of
your listeners owns a duplex that
they're running out well that's an
alternative investment there are funds
like life settlement funds that buy life
insurance policies and I think these are
kind of interesting there's there's this
whole market that started and it started
in a terrible way I mean back in the 80s
you know people were buying life
insurance policies from young men that
were sick with AIDS and the what I like
about the happy ending to that story is
of course they came up with a cure for
that and all the people that had thought
they were buying these policies and
we're gonna cash in wound up going
bankrupt so I like the way that story
ends ends but what happened is some
states started regulating this space and
saying look if you want to sell a life
insurance policy or buy a life insurance
policy you have to go through a
regulated process and once that happened
you know some actuaries came into the
space and and private firms came in a
space and started buying policies and
about you know
3/4 of people over the age of 70 they
wind up surrendering their life
insurance policy they go back to
wherever they bought the policy and go I
don't need this anymore and the
insurance company goes great we'll give
you the surrender value back so someone
might have a three million dollar policy
that was going to pay to their family
but now they're 70 and they're their
house has paid for their kids are out of
college they don't need them they don't
need that anymore but they want their
hundred thousand cash value back because
they can enjoy it over the next ten
years or twenty years of their life well
instead these life settlement funds come
along and go hey we'll buy that policy
from you and they might pay five ten or
12 times more you know where the funds
we use is playing about twelve times
more for that policy so they might give
that guy 1.2 million dollars for that
policy so that guy's thrilled you know
they're running off with their money
they're getting way more than they were
gonna get from the insurance company
but now the fund owns you know maybe a
thousand plus life-insurance policies
and they're going to collect all those
death benefits and they distribute it to
the people that invested in the fund so
that's also an alternative investment
has nothing to do with stocks bonds real
estate but it's a little different and
people like it investments like that
because they don't behave the way the
stock market or the bond market does
they don't care who's the president they
don't care what what's going on with
tariffs or who tweets what this is
actuarial science as far as how these
how this fund is going to do there's a
fund that buys music royalties so it
might buy the like a catalogue or songs
from different artists and then own the
future royalties and your performance is
dependent on do people still download
those songs five years from now 20 years
from now but the alternative investment
space is very interesting governed by a
little bit different set of rules and I
think that's where higher net worth
people can get an edge but beyond just
going with needs based investing mm-hmm
you mentioned real estate a few times
and I'd like to touch on that because
this is a an asset class if we can
depending on how we want to want to look
at it an asset class that I think a lot
of people feel a certain degree of
comfort with rightly or wrongly because
it is very
tangible and some people would would
would argue that real estate is a better
investment than the stock market or they
maybe intuitively and wrongly feel that
is the case what is your perspective on
on real estate and I know that that that
is a broad term but maybe you could
expand on your your thinking as it
relates to to real estate well I like
real estate as an investment as
particularly its if it's diversified I
do think that in the private side
expertise makes a very very big
difference but I will also tell you real
estate in my experience is a
tremendously overrated investment and I
have some clients that are extremely
wealthy from running real estate but I
also have some that went bankrupt with
their private real estate and I'm gonna
give you a couple of reasons I think
it's overrated I think it's
misunderstood I think one of the things
is if you look at a business look at how
big business works if you are one of the
fortune 100 companies
I'd rather own the company than the
building that they rent and so would
they you know most of these big
companies they sell off their real
estate because they feel it will drag
down their rate of return and when a
private equity firm goes and buys a
business that has 100 million of revenue
they don't want to buy the building
they're very happy for the owner to keep
the building and pay that owner rent
because they think the real estate is
going to hurt their rate of return so if
you really look at the very big
sophisticated money they'd rather own
the business that's in the property than
the property that the business is in now
second I think real estate magnifies
wins and losses so you're gonna see a
disproportionate amount of winners so
let's say that you're going to go buy a
duplex and it's a hundred thousand
dollars and that doesn't exist where you
live but where I live it does so let's
gonna buy a hundred thousand dollar
duplex and you just put down ten
thousand dollars and you borrow ninety
thousand from the bank and let's say
that you know you rent out the duplex
and the real estate markets good
interest rates are low and now your
duplex is worth a hundred and ten
thousand dollars and you sell it your
gain is a hundred percent
right you put $10,000 in and now you're
selling it you you're paying off your
loan and you have a $10,000 profit so
you've doubled your $10,000 investment
that use of leverage magnifies gains and
makes people think the investment is
better than it is now the reason you see
a tremendous amount of bankruptcies in
real estate is it works in Reverse right
we we saw that in Oh 809 during the most
devastating example of this in US
history where you know you put ten
thousand in and you borrow ninety
thousand and you own a hundred thousand
dollar duplex and then the market
crashes and you're a hundred thousand
dollar duplex is worth ninety thousand
well you've lost a hundred percent of
your investment when you sell right so
you're magnifying the wins and losses
and you can do that with anything but
people are very comfortable doing it
with real estate so for example I could
take a portfolio with a hundred thousand
dollars and I can go borrow against the
portfolio I could borrow fifty grand if
I wanted to against the portfolio and
invest that money and I'd have a hundred
and fifty thousand dollar portfolio with
a fifty thousand dollar loan most people
would go my god that's risky I mean I'm
not gonna borrow money against my
portfolio to buy more stocks but that's
basically what we're doing when we're
using leverage in real estate we're
really counting on the value of real
estate to hold and then third I would
say the thing about real estate is
unless you are tremendously diversified
real estate is an investment where
everything is okay until it isn't okay I
mean when it goes bad it it will go it
can go bad very very quickly so in the
community that I'm in there's was a
family that became extremely wealthy
with shopping malls and then all of a
sudden those weren't in favor and it's
this story doesn't end so well it's the
same thing with how neighborhoods that
you might have been to when you were
growing up if you look at the complexion
of them today some of them hold up and
some of them all of the real estate may
as well be worthless I mean and so I
think I think it's it's a deceptive
investment there you feel this security
because you can see it and you can touch
it a lot of people get rich in it
because of leverage we tend to ignore
the people that go bankrupt and we tend
to not look at those parts of town that
didn't turn out so well that we're
pretty
parts of town 10 or 20 years earlier so
I'll again I like it I've come across
like I'm not I just think it's overrated
we own a lot of real estate for our
clients private and public at creative
planning I personally own private and
public real estate I like it as an asset
class but people really need to focus on
diversification and understanding where
it fits in if you own a public real
estate fund and you own the stock fund
your expectation should be that 20 years
later you've made more owning the
companies than owning the buildings that
they read mm-hmm thank you for that and
I want to ask about another asset class
that may make me immediately seem like a
complete idiot we'll see probably not
the only thing in this conversation I
think we look like complete idiot but
well I'll just start tallying those up
on one side but but for similar reasons
the tangibility the sort of personal
concrete nature of this class I want to
ask about it and then the jointly with
real estate will lead to a follow-up
question that I have for you artwork in
investing in art what are what are your
thoughts does it have a place is it
overrated underrated how should one say
how would you encourage people to think
about that or how do you think about it
well I think would you look at things
like that or collectibles or cars not
not a car you would just go buy to drive
around but but the cars that are more
collectible oriented to me those are
like collecting coins we're counting on
there being a marketplace that exists
for it and I think we have a
centuries-old legacy of that being the
case with art and so I don't consider
that a fad by any mean by any means and
there are funds that specialize in
owning art we wouldn't use them with our
clients because we really want things
that produce income so to me I consider
there are a lot of ways to make money
and I'd rather make money in a way where
that I've got a the hammock there the
safety net there to back up into I like
that if I own bonds or stocks or real
estate that
things declined for a prolonged period
of time I can still collect money I can
still collect if the housing market goes
down I own some duplexes but keep him
running I'm still gonna collect the rent
whereas if I've invested in art and the
market turns against me for a decade or
two and I want to sell something I'm not
going to make any money in the mean time
but for someone who I like that kind of
investment if you also have a passion
that goes with it
so if somebody likes art they have
enough money and I mean a lot of money
millions of dollars to where you're
moving you don't need this money to be
financially independent if it works out
fantastic if it doesn't work out it's
not going to kill you the collectible
markets can work but they have a little
bit more speculative element to them so
I'm gonna turn this into a bit of a
personalized therapy session for a
moment the reason I bring up real estate
and are is that they coincide with or
have similarities to for me early-stage
tech investing in the sense that one of
the primary bugs which is illiquidity
has turned out to be a a huge feature
and benefit for me given my
psychological weaknesses and propensity
to impulse sell or panic sell does that
make sense so I have been able to guard
against my lesser behaviors by having
certain assets like early-stage tech
which I do not recommend to everyone by
any stretch of the imagination because
I've done a tremendous amount of upfront
due diligence and analysis or had
superior information have made
investments and then been completely
prevented to my benefit in most cases
from selling those assets until they get
to a certain escape velocity and
similarly if if I buy real estate and I
do own real estate the fees and
complexity involved on some level with
unwinding those versus going to a
brokerage account just hitting sell on
my
public equity that I might own guards
against one of my most financially
self-defeating behaviors which is panic
selling so I suppose this could lead us
into a bunch of different territory but
I'm curious to know when things that
broadly speaking don't make financial
sense if we were computers looking at
asset classes and so on and so forth
actually makes sense for individual
clients because of their frailty and
being human or weaknesses like those
that I outlined and and the answer might
be there's a better way to prevent me
from making stupid mistakes but I'd love
to hear any and all thoughts you have on
that brain vomit that I just threw up on
you
I actually I'm I'm so glad you asked
this I wouldn't have thought of it as a
question but I would say that you know
earlier I was talking about I think that
the things that derails people are
exactly what you talked about their
behavioral and those really tend to come
from uncertainty if you don't know
what's going on
uncertainty leads to fear if you go to a
doctor and and you you have something
that's they think might be terminal but
they're not sure I mean you're gonna be
scared out of your mind or the doctors
trying to figure something out you're
not going to feel good the more
uncertainty there is the more fear
you're gonna have and I think that's
what you're talking about with your
experience of the markets as you're
uncertain about outcomes it makes you
scared and then what do you do you you
might sell because it's so easy to sell
and what what helps alleviate
uncertainty is education you know the
more informed you are the more you
understand how the investments you're in
work and and what their time horizon is
like and how frequently Corrections and
bear markets are and how rapid things
can go down but how rapid they come back
the more educated you become the the
more certainty you get the less fear you
have the more likely you are to stick
with the plan but despite all of that
even the wealthiest people or the most
educated people get scared and down
markets I mean I'm seeing it today you
know as we speak you know that the your
listeners are listed this later that the
Dow is probably about 4,000 points off
of its high and that freaks some people
out
according this just for context in late
December December 21st 2018 well I I
just last week saw someone who is
running a state pension in an interview
say he felt like he was paying a premium
for alternative investments so he could
be blissfully unaware of how poor the
investments are doing in a down-cycle
and I think there's something to that I
remember in the Oh eight oh nine crisis
we meet with all of our clients to do a
complete review on top of all of the
things we're doing throughout the year
and we we go through everything on their
net worth and then we rerun the plan
make sure we're on the same page and
here we go through and we update all of
their investments and we're showing them
you know this investment in stocks is
down this investment and in your
publicly traded real estate is down and
your bonds are up or whatever it is and
then we'd get to their house and they'd
say oh my house is the same value and
then we'd get to that duplex they own
that they ran out like oh that's the
same value and that painting in my house
it's the same value of course it's not
the same value right if they wanted to
go sell the house or the duplex or the
art they'd actually have to take a
bigger discount at most of the time then
the public markets I mean there was
literally no buyers for any of that you
weren't going to go sell a
million-dollar coin collection in them
in the middle of all that and so the not
having it updated every second of every
hour of every business day allows people
to be blissfully unaware and not make
those behavioral mistakes and so I
actually do think that's a positive you
know when we have our higher net worth
clients that have alternatives
I like the alternatives because I think
they're going to get a little bit better
return I think they may have a little
less volatility but I also think it
speaks directly to what you brought up
it brings them peace and that it's not
priced every single day and so every
single time the markets trend down they
don't have to be reminded that that
they've seen their public real estate
down on in their account but they're not
seeing the private real estate down
because it's not repriced every day and
it really does help people not make
long-term mistakes if we're looking at
long term avoiding mitigating against
long term
mistakes suppose we could also talk
about short-term mistakes now the young
the considering how reluctant I am to
involve invest in public markets and one
could argue stupidly so I've read a
tremendous amount so so I am it's it's
not that I'm uninformed as it relates to
the trending over time of say the equity
market but what catches me in and you
noted in some of our exchanges prior to
this conversation that in my podcast
with Howard Marks in legendary investor
that I brought up fear of losing money
and yes it just it seems to me and maybe
you can talk some sense into me but that
on one hand you can argue or one could
argue that it's not timing the market
but time in the market that makes the
difference right and that the time to
get started is now on the other hand
couldn't one also argue that while it's
very possible if not very sorry
difficult if not impossible to time the
market it is very very possible to miss
time the market not by design but by
accident and if you come in at the top
of the market I know you talked about
like the day before 9/11 etc the the
recovery time in some cases isn't
necessarily trivial right so it is there
I then just follow me here there's gonna
be a little long but if there there are
smart people and maybe this is just like
the guy with the sandwich board on the
corner saying the end is near is
eventually gonna be right so who knows
maybe this is one of those cases but you
have some very smart people who
historically hold a lot in cash for when
there's blood in the streets at least
that's my understanding like a Seth
Klarman or others my inclination would
be if you tell me that the markets are
down one out of every four years is to
wait for the canary in the coalmine or
some type of indicator maybe it's
obvious maybe it isn't
that we are down and then hold on to
cash until that point - and to invest
when the market is not necessarily at
its all-time low for that period of time
but lower than it should be
so to speak and this is going to come
off as terribly naive for a lot of folks
but the reason I bring this up is that
it seems to me that the and this is me
kind of talking out my ass a little bit
but that the function of investing is to
ultimately on some level improve your
quality of life so if you invest in
vehicles or assets that caused you
heartburn and anxiety to the extent you
have trouble sleeping even if they have
a really high IRR or whatever is a bad
investment from the standpoint of
quality of life if it's creating a lot
of additional stress so I have no
trouble sleeping when my money is in
cash even though it's getting slowly
eaten by inflation like termites so if
in an ideal world I would be able to
wait until everyone thinks that we're
going to Mad Max and then dump money in
to the market much like how it marks tit
in the last say 15 weeks or so 2008
right where he's putting in five hundred
million a week and two distressed debt
where where am I going wrong here and
how should I think about this or how
would you add to that I know that's a
ton that I just threw at you but if you
could do your best
well I I would say that I would start
with I would agree completely that
nothing is worth losing sleep I mean
money is just something that enables us
to do you know other things that's
presumably we want to be happy so
there's no sense in being miserable
investing it so we can supposedly do you
know something else so I'm not a
believer that if somebody comes in and
they have enough money where they could
be independent for the rest of their
lives living off bond income and they
tell me Peter I'm you know 70 and you're
not going to be able to make me
comfortable and I'm gonna lose sleep if
my portfolio goes down five percent I'm
not going to talk that person in the
stocks or real estate or or alternative
investments they should be in bonds
because they have all they need they're
not telling me their goal
to have the biggest pile of money ever
or to be like the greatest steward of
their money ever for the next generation
they're telling me I want to be happy
with what I have I don't need to hit hit
even a double let alone a home run and I
want to sleep at night sleeping at night
trumps everything you have to absolutely
be comfortable with with what you're
what you're doing now you're so young
that I would work on somebody like you
and say well let's wait a second because
we've got a couple choices here one is
that you get comfortable with investing
which means you're going to get there
you need to get more educated about how
public markets work so we can make you
more comfortable so you could have more
certainty about it so you can be a
long-term investor because you are going
to be invested for many many many
decades and it's extremely likely you
know that's really going to work out for
you you only have two other choices one
is to own cash which is a complete
disaster I mean that's not it should not
really be an option and the third is to
add tremendous complexity to your life
so you say I'm gonna buy all these
different properties and all these
different our art thing and you're gonna
wake up one day and you're gonna own a
whole bunch of all this crap it's gonna
be on your net worth tape and I can tell
you the cycles and I've learned this
from my clients and I've changed my
behavior because of it you know that as
people start to accumulate wealth people
come to them with deals and they get
excited that hey there
these deals are coming to me one Indian
client translated an Indian saying to me
he said that his dad had told them that
the saying money pulls money and he
didn't know what it meant until he had
money and then all of a sudden people
were coming to him with deals that
seemed great and it became easier and
easier to make money I'm sure that's the
case for you and so you wind up doing
all these deals and you find yourself in
real estate and venture capital and
private deals and you're growing growing
growing and then a friend dies and
another friend dies and then you go oh
my God look at what hat look at the what
the survivors are dealing with here what
a mess this is and you start to unwind
all of these things so you spend the
first 20 years of being rich
accumulating all this stuff and then
you'll spend the next 20 years if you're
like at least the clients I've observed
trying to get out of one thing after
another to simplify your life and
somewhere along the way you'll wind up
with 20 different tax forms and all the
stuff that you don't have to do because
you chose
not to get educated and I think that
let's just use one education forming you
obviously you highlighted its time in
the market right I mean I I know Howard
Marks said that Warren Buffett said that
that's a very obvious thing you don't
expect that you're gonna go to the store
and pay less for a coke or less for a
candy bar thirty years from now than
today you know you probably think the
candy bar is going to cost triple but
somehow you have this fear that the
stock is that is not gonna triple right
and of course those two go together you
know part of the stock market returns
the dividend part of its earnings and
part is just inflation I mean so we we
know we're gonna go to McDonald's thirty
years from now and the happy meal is
gonna cost more and the value meals
gonna cost more but we're scared to own
the diversified stock portfolio and if
you're diversified you know we should
feel very comfortable so you might in a
year in Austin it's a great restaurant
town but you know the world moves
quickly you know back in the 70s or 80s
if a restaurant opened and it wasn't
very good someone would go oh you know
this restaurant might close in a few
years if you go to a restaurant now and
it's not very good you wouldn't be
surprised if it was closed in six months
I mean the world just moves really fast
now and if I said hey Tim I want you to
pick five restaurants in town that you
think are amazing and you had to put all
your money in them and that they're
gonna be here thirty years from now you
might think twice I mean it doesn't
matter what the restaurant is I would
definitely think twice especially the
restaurants you you would be like no
matter how good the restaurant is thirty
years from now if things will have
probably changed but if I were to say
look you can own the restaurant index so
we're no longer betting on you know
which five restaurants are going to be
here thirty years from now or you could
you could lose your money we're just
betting that there are going to be
restaurants here and they're going to be
charging more and making more than they
do today you'd be much more comfortable
with that and that's very much like
diversified stock market investing and
so when the more you can learn about
that and when you're gonna need the
money and that hey if you're in the
stock market and it's down probably that
prot those private investments you have
that aren't repricing every day many of
those are down as well you can start to
build
at least some some portfolio to that you
could start to get educated on you go
through your first correction you go
through your first bear market and then
if you're young and you're really smart
you can really tell the very smart
investors they like down markets right
because if you're accumulating you don't
want the market to go up you you want
the market to be up later when you need
to take money out but if you're
accumulating you would like it to be
down you want to be buying everything
when it's on a discount so my clients
that are sophisticated they're
accumulating now they love this
downtrend they feel like they're buying
more and more on sale or clients that
have a lot of bond exposure and they can
sell some of their bonds and buy stocks
they love that down market because they
see it for what it is which is an
opportunity quick question there do you
know any people you think are really
smart who do not dollar-cost average in
on the way down in that camp but who
instead sit on the sidelines waiting for
some indicators that that is not a
bottom I'm not not saying they predict
the absolute bottom or the relative
bottom during that period of time but do
you do you know anyone you consider
smart who does not sort of dollar-cost
average in on the way down as as a way
to I think you put it in the acquisition
phase now I think it's a loser's game I
heard John Bogle you know the founder of
Vanguard and indexing say that isn't in
Titan tire life he never found somebody
that was able to do that effectively
he's never found the guy who sold what
it was high and then bought when it was
low I've been at this now 20 years we
have over 30,000 clients many of them
have self-directed accounts I can tell
you I've never seen it done never I've
never seen somebody go the markets high
now and sell and then feel comfortable
buying when when it's low I I've seen
people who are invested and they stay
invested and then they are more
aggressive about adding to the portfolio
when it's down I consider that much me
know much smarter approach
but I the guy who goes today oh those
aren't easy I'm gonna go to the
sidelines if the market gets cut in half
that that guy usually doesn't have the
intestinal fortitude to go in you know
there's all these other reasons that
things are horrible and now that
narrative that caused them to exit in
the first place
is reinforced right so they they have
even more reason to stay on the
sidelines and they usually don't get
back back in in time you know you would
ask the question earlier about well why
don't I wait for that one in four years
for that pullback and we could use the
last 10 years as an example I mean the
market can go from Dow 7,000 to 26,000
like it did without having a bear market
in them anywhere in the middle of it for
you to invest in right so this year we
have an if the year ended today on the
21st of December in 2018 the market
would be down but it's nowhere near
where it was nine years ago if you had
gone to the sidelines and known oh nine
and said I'm gonna accumulate cash until
the market pulls back again you had
waited ten years for the next real big
opportunity so now the markets pulled
back by not back to where it was and I
think this is the risk that people that
are trying to time don't understand
which is the risk of being out of the
market is greater than the risk of being
in so let's say you have a million
dollars and you go into the market today
one of three things can happen the
market can go up we're high-fiving you
know having a great time we're all happy
the market can go sideways and you're
gonna earn a couple percent that's not
the end of the world we're getting our
dividends right now or the market could
go down okay
the worst thing there is you collect
dividends and then the market comes back
right so we've we've had dozens of bear
markets you know many many many more
Corrections they happen on average once
a year where the market drops usually on
average about 13 and a half percent or
so they've all ended the same way you
know the markets eventually recover so
you collect your dividend you wait
that's your worst-case scenario as an
investor if instead you're in cash well
if the market goes down we're not
getting the dividend and you're probably
going to want to stay in cash if the
market goes sideways we're not
collecting the dividend if the market
goes up we maze
suffer permanent loss of opportunity so
the Dow goes from 20 2030 you may never
the market may never pull back to that
22 it may never come back to that level
that entry point that you had been
afforded the opportunity today when
you're on the sidelines you are risking
the market getting away from you when
you're in it can't get away from you it
can temporarily downtrend with you along
with it but you can't miss that
opportunity which is why anybody that is
looking at the odds of investing they're
going to be invested sooner rather than
later gotcha
and when you say the word diversify or a
diversification has come up a number of
times so far am I am i accurate and
saying that you have a diversified
public portfolio to maintain or
incrementally increase net worth while
searching for alpha primarily through
alternative investments is that the
general approach and then I have a
question about what diversification
means but is that is that a fair
synopsis of generally what you are
advocating with your clients yeah what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
perform better than they would on their
own or with somebody else by being
extremely disciplined placing taxed
rates being aggressive buyers owning
asset classes that match up with their
needs and diversification to me means
you try to reduce dramatically company
risk and industry risk when you're an
investor in the stock market let's start
with that you've got three big risks
what is company risk so you buy a stock
and it turns out to be Enron or real
calm or Lehman Brothers or Polaroid or
whatever it just goes to zero that's
company risk
there's industry risk you know if you
are in the mortgage-backed securities
market in o8 or if you were part of the
internet craze of the internet bubble
I mean industries go away sometimes and
never recover and then there's market
risk you know if you if you're very
diversified you're across a bunch of
companies a bunch of industries if
there's a Lehman Brothers in there if
there's an industry and they're like not
doing well you're gonna survive and the
market risk it's a temporary risky the
market will go down and then it should
back up and we can diversify the market
risk further by owning other markets
like real estate and bonds and then we
can get extremely diversified by going
into the alternative investments face
and that would be an investment approach
you said something a little earlier that
people have different purposes you know
some people are they're trying to hit a
home run and some people are trying to
invest
I would say in investing is what I just
described in the markets you you have to
approach investing saying this is not
going to do as well as my day job yeah
so what I'm sitting with a business
owner or whether the guy owns a
restaurant or the gal owns a consulting
firm I tell them look you're making 30%
on your money with your job or more you
are not going to make that in the market
don't come to me if you think that's
what's going to happen right that's just
not what happens when you invest this
way for the long run now you could make
a business out of investing in these
markets so you could for example be a
real estate developer and yeah you're
gonna do much better than just somebody
who's buying a diversified real estate
portfolio but now you're in this
full-time right
same thing with Ray Dalio on the stock
side if you want to buy into the idea
that maybe he can win over time it would
be because it's a full-time it's a
full-time job that might use a different
approach that a typical disciplined
investor would use so I think you have
to come into a portfolio like someone
like you is going I've got my day job
I'm doing all these things and taking
all these risks and using my time to
make a lot of money and I'm going to
invest in a way we're all do better than
cash but I'll never make what I'm making
with my time and effort and name and
everything else but I but I'm going to
do better than this then cash I'm gonna
do better than bonds by by having a
disciplined diversified approach mm-hm
it does diversified in this case because
people often think diversified means
buying a lot of stuff right but if you
buy a lot of stuff and to anyone who's
professional out there obviously I'm
mostly talking on my ass right now but
if everything is correlated even though
they are different words or different
asset classes then you may not be truly
diversified right see if you look at
say David Swensen or some of these other
guys they might talk about US stocks
international stocks emerging market
REITs long-term US Treasuries and
Treasury and tips right or something
like that right
wood or Dalio fifteen uncorrelated bets
right something like that
what is diversified mean to you think
what are the characteristics of a
diversified portfolio and is it possible
to over diversify where you're just
spraying and praying it in in a sense
yeah I think the versification is
misunderstood sometimes people think
like you mentioned at the very top of
the podcast hey I'm gonna hire for money
managers and I'll be more diversified
than one that's not necessarily the case
maybe all for money managers are trading
US stocks you'd have been better off
with one wealth manager who owns four
different asset classes right so
sometimes diversifying money managers
doesn't do it you might buy five
duplexes in Nashville on the same block
well you're not that diversified you
have the risk of the neighborhood and of
the city and of the state
I'd rather own five different properties
in five different states to get a little
bit more diversified certain asset
classes are correlated in real estates
about 85% correlated to stocks and the
US markets you know 80 90 percent
correlated to international markets and
bonds have a little bit of correlation
so you want to add things that don't
necessarily you want to remove the
concentrated risk you don't want to own
the five duplexes on one street you
don't have five money managers doing one
thing you don't want to have five stocks
and hope one's not illumine brothers or
one or two industries that have a
hundred stocks I mean if you want a
hundred stocks and they're all biotech
you're not you're not really diversified
you want to own asset classes that
behave a little bit different in some
cases like US and international and and
that behave a lot different over periods
of time like bonds relative to those
things or maybe art would or life
settlements would or music royalties
would so the extent you could have those
uncorrelated assets it dampens the ride
which makes it more likely you're going
to get where you want to go and most
importantly it avoids the number one
thing everybody worries about which is
blowing everything up right on you you
don't want to do everything right for 30
years but
the stock or the industry or the real
estate market you were in something
unforeseen happen and all of the sudden
nothing works for you you are
eliminating the chance of the grand slam
when you do this but you are almost
eliminating the chance of the strikeout
which is a very important thing for an
investor mm-hmm
so let's the run a hypothetical if you
don't mind and this is going to again
probably make half the people listening
just facepalm as I say this but let's
just pretend well it's not pretend it's
real so let's say that I I am seeing
things in the private markets which give
me pause and make me think that there's
a possibility that the winter is coming
so to speak as it relates to public
equities specifically if I think that
there is a decent chance of a fairly
major extended correction in say the
next two years if that's my assumption
whether you agree with it or not
how would that inform my decision-making
about deploying cash how would you how
would you think about it if if if that
is something I take to be likely true
you know there's a saying a famous
economist said that that the market
could stay solvent you you the market
can stay irrational longer than you can
stay solvent in other words it's just
very hard I mean even if the what you're
touching on I think that's interesting
is returns in the market over the next
year or two are not really dependent on
valuations and that really surprises
people so something can be overvalued
but then not come down in price instead
the earnings grow into it you can own a
real estate property and maybe it seems
overvalued but instead of the prices
coming down the price holds and over
time the rents come up so not
necessarily does the price of the
property have to come down it's the same
with the stock market but if I take your
premise that you have a high degree of
certainty that the market's going to go
pull back 18 months from now well of
course I would say well just wait for it
to pull back and then go in I've just
never met the person that can do that or
no matter how smart they are or and look
I'm sitting we're sitting with some of
the wealthiest people in America and I'm
sitting with some of the most
sophisticated money managers in America
too and I just don't I don't live in a
world where the person can predict that
I was I listen to your podcast with
Howard Marks and he said you know we're
were invested but were cautious well I
mean he that guy's a genius but he's in
you know you're he's invested right you
you're either in or you're out and so I
I think that we're all always looking to
the future and wondering what's gonna
happen but you look at the most
successful investors like Warren Buffett
they're engaged they're engaged all the
time that's how they got where they are
I think it's important to note though
that also there are different economics
at play and different incentives
involved in some instances when you're
using institutional money or playing
with a like two-and-twenty meaning you
have management fees and assets under
management are a component of your
business versus playing with your
personal capital right I mean I know a
lot of venture capitalists who invest
with one very distinct style or approach
in their venture deals but treat their
personal finances very very differently
right there's no question like a lot of
the venture capital and private equity
people I know they're invested almost
entirely in bonds because they feel like
they're in an extremely high-risk game
day in and day out with their with their
side of things I think you look at
Swenson and you're investing yells money
you're investing for decades you're not
really investing for you know five or
six years from now but what I would say
is the average American investor you
know whether they've got a hundred
thousand dollars or two million dollars
they are investing for decades and they
should be thinking that way even the
person who's retiring tomorrow who's 65
is investing for decades and so if we
have an expectation that stocks are
earn six to nine percent or maybe ten
percent over the next 20 years and Real
Estate's gonna earn five to eight and
bonds are gonna earn three to five or
whatever it is that person that 65 can't
say I need this money now I need to be
conservative they need the money for the
next 25 years and we need money that's
available to them over the next five and
we need money that that's going to be
available to available to them 20 years
from now and so I do think that
diversified multiple asset class leaning
on a publicly traded portfolio that
really should be the core for the
typical investor and I think when you
start to leave that you are taking extra
risks even when you go to these
alternative investments whether it's
private equity private lending private
real estate we're now giving custody of
our money to somebody else
we don't have total transparency we
can't exit whenever we want we're much
more susceptible to fraud it's just
there's a lot more unknowns in that
space and so if you're very wealthy
you're going for better returns you
don't like to see the public markets all
the time I mean there's a case to be
made for them but not I don't think
exclusively not even for the typical I
think for the typical American a
diversified portfolios still the core
building block let's talk about
information for a second and just
resources because I've read unshakeable
of course which which I greatly enjoyed
money master the game I've two episodes
with Tony about that which which I quite
enjoyed as well
what other I know you've you've you've
written books I mean the five mistakes
every investor makes and how to avoid
them besides those books and we're going
to come back to that title I just
mentioned in a few minutes but what what
what books or investors who have writing
rights who have something accessible to
the people listening do you have you
have you found particularly valuable or
thought-provoking are there any
particular books or annual letters or
well if anything that comes to mind when
a book that I read when I was very young
that I thought really kind of explained
the investing world in plain English and
it was in pretty short was common sense
on mutual funds by John Bogle and it
kind of goes back and it compares all
these things we talked about the the
benefits of timing versus not timing the
market and of stock picking versus nots
pick stock picking and how to choose an
allocation and it was just so
straightforward I really I really think
that's a great read for somebody just
trying to understand the basics and so I
I always tend to recommend that as one
of my one of my recommendations to
people when they're looking for a book
to really explain things in English
mm-hmm
what what about particular investors are
there any particular investors who come
to mind who's who's thinking you really
admire side aside from Buffett and
Munger because they're always on the
list or they seem to be are there any
other they could be less or no names
they don't have to be who come to mind
who who you find particularly insightful
or thoughts thought-provoking well I
mean I think this is this might be too
much in the Box given that what you laid
out but he was the bent or some of the
people you mentioned I mean Benjamin
Graham's the intelligent investors a
phenomenal book as well and I I really
enjoy that one and would recommend that
to your listeners as well mm-hmm got it
what is the best or most worthwhile
investment you've ever made and that
this is a one of my fairly common
questions I suppose but it's not
necessarily capital I mean it could be
but a time money energy something that
really had a high return on investment
in your life has anything does anything
come to mind yeah so when I was in
college I was in Lawrence which is a
great you know music town and I really
got into music and I invested I care if
it was 10,000 or 12,000 dollars and
decided I was gonna set up a store that
bought and sold CDs and cassette tapes
kind of dating myself a little bit here
and I had a couple partners and we
opened the store and it did really well
we took our money and we opened another
store it did really well and we kept
doing this and we got I was eight or
nine stores then I bought out one
partner and then I bought out the other
and at that point I'd been in this gig
for you know five or six years and I
thought well I'm bought out everybody
I'm gonna take my first paycheck and I
took my first paycheck out it was eighty
four hundred dollars and then a month
later Napster came out and within six
months almost every location was closed
and all the CDs had been donated to a
charity and that was the best education
I had I mean I have a guy I did a lot
when I was in college I had a lot of
greedy bastards in business some
undergrad degrees that was the best
investment and the best education I ever
got in my life still to this day was the
total loss of all of that time and all
of that money but what you really what I
really learned was a real world you know
example of supply and demand and how
quick you can grow and how there's a
window of opportunity that every
business dies every business dies I know
that the Bezos of Amazon says that all
the time you know every every business
sears one of the greatest business of
all time last a century last a century
that's almost unheard of the sp500 is
changing all the time now because
companies are companies just rise and
fall much quicker than they ever have
I learned that firsthand and I also
learned how quickly technology can
change everything I thought I was
competing against the music store across
the street and the music store in the
mall and I was competing against
something I didn't even know existed
that was going to come in and destroy
everything you know Walmart thought it
was competing with Target its competing
with Amazon right and so that was really
to me a lesson in how quick you can grow
something how the economy works how
quick you can be replaced and it it it
really Illustrated for me how big money
can be made with concentrated risk and
total loss can happen from concentrated
risk so that that takes the cake for me
I'll never have an investment that good
I attribute a lot of my success of and
paranoia of when I run creative planning
and I'm looking at the landscape
been going you know what are the threats
I'm looking at it with as wide a lens as
can possibly be I don't think for a
second that any business is invincible
and and that for will ever be the
greatest investment I ever made that's a
great story yeah yeah what you were
competing against is something you don't
even know exists that's how often is
that true at least it's it's certainly
something that you see a lot in tech and
Silicon Valley I mean the the biggest
threat is not what you've identified is
the biggest threat in many instances so
coming back to your your book the five
mistakes every investor makes know how
to avoid them just published by Wiley in
2014 in an interview that I read doing
homework for this conversation
the the question from the interviewer
this is from think advisor was what's
the biggest mistake and feel free to
fact-check this correct if I'm
misquoting but the answer is I have it
here is quote people don't enjoy their
money especially the extra up sorry
ultra affluent obsessive client has
millions of dollars they've spent a lot
of time doing the right thing saving and
making good decisions and being focused
on growing growing growing but when they
get to retirement they can't turn off
those traits that made them successful
they keep doing the things they always
did being thrifty maybe a little stingy
so they don't spend their money for
enjoyment and then they die this is not
me talking from what I can tell really
really really common not just with ultra
affluent types but with a lot of people
across the board they save they save
they say but the kind of mistake the
means for the end in in some capacity or
they can't downshift like you mentioned
and they kind of lose track of why they
were amassing or building this wealth in
the first place so what do you what do
you tell these clients who can't turn it
off the people who keep doing things the
way they always did the people who don't
spend their money for enjoyment what is
their homework that you give them what
is the conversation that you have I tell
them I tell them true stories that are
both personal and about existing clients
all I'm going to share one that was
personal and one existing client I had a
client he
retired fairly young at 63 at least
seems young and the very first day and
he would come in four years and talk
about how he wanted to garden and that
was his dream and all that he never
would spend any of his money never would
go on vacations never do anything like
that and the very first day of
retirement he died and his wife was in
the and I think every adviser that has a
bunch of clients has a story like this
and his wife came in and she was just so
upset that he had passed but that he she
had found his to-do list he didn't call
it a bucket list but it was it was his
bucket list and he'd only done like one
or two things on that list there were
all these things that they could have
done together that he never got to
experience and he robbed her of that too
you know that that issue that he had
I've I've got to save I got to save I've
got to save I can't enjoy it along the
way he robbed her of that I got really
in tune with this at a young age because
my dad you know vacations all the time
he's a he's a physician but he takes a
lot of breaks and I learned that from
him and he had mentioned to me there's a
there's a famous person in Kansas City
where I'm based he had been the the
mayor and there's a lot of stuff here
named after him and he was a patient of
my dad's and one day he got diagnosed he
was very ill and he was gonna die and he
my dad was just in his 20s at the time
and he told my dad to sit he sit down
I've got a lesson for you and my dad
like that town and he just said I've got
this named after me and that road named
after me and that buildings named after
me and I've accumulated all this money
but I never really got to enjoy it I
never really got to enjoy my family and
that's very cliche right we but but my
dad took that and he said I am NOT gonna
be this guy right and I looked at some
of my clients that have made that
mistake and I tell myself the same thing
we also do estate planning here we
prepare wills and trusts and so on so
we're very unique last week one of our
one of my favorite clients passed and
his kids came in and so I get to see the
kids because we're also I'm also an
estate attorney and there are a lot of
estate attorneys here and so we're here
for them we already know them
and we get to see that next generation
but what I also see is that the person
that couldn't let go you know there are
people that spend everything they have
and there's people that can't let go of
anything and then there's a very tiny
group in the middle that is saving what
they're supposed to do and spending with
what they did is spend to enjoy that
that's a very small group but these
people that are saving all the time
they're in the minority right they might
be my client and I might be seeing them
all the time but they're in the minority
and they're not they're not going on
that cruise ship they don't get the
balcony and when they're flying on a
plane they don't get the the business
class and they don't get the tall thing
at Starbucks because why would somebody
pay six dollars for that that's just not
in their DNA that's part of how they got
where they are and then they die and
then their kids come in and they're
coming in and they've got the Starbucks
in their hand and I've had people show
up in brand new cars as BMW or whatever
that the parents are barely in the grave
and the kids are spending the money and
so I try to get them to visualize what
you actually think is going to happen
when you pass if you have three million
dollars and you've got two kids what do
you think is gonna happen to that three
million that what do you think they're
gonna do think about their spouses think
about their kids and think of how they
live and what are they gonna do and they
go they're gonna buy a house they're
gonna do that I go exactly and they
start to think about their money a
little bit differently because if you've
got three million dollars and you really
enjoy yourself out of your mind
you might die with two million well you
know what your kids aren't going to
notice the difference and if you have
$300,000 and you die with two hundred
thousand set a three hundred thousand
the kids aren't going to notice the
difference you it's the perspective of
visualizing what is actually going to
happen if you don't enjoy this a little
bit of yourself and then they'll give
you excuses and and the two big excuses
are I want to save it for my kids or I
want to save it for charities and you
know I always tell them give it to your
kids net give some of it to them now so
you can enjoy it so you can alleviate
then they're going through the most
stressful time of their life trying to
pay for college or trying to save for
retirement why don't you give them some
money now when they could really use it
instead of you dying at 80 and their 60
and they don't have those problems
anymore if you want to give to charity
it's better to give with a warm hand
than a cold one you know give while you
can enjoy it while you can see what
you're doing with it while you can make
sure the charity is doing what you want
so I I spend a lot of time talking to
this with our clients because I just
think it's a it's a shame you see these
people these tend to be very disciplined
people and they they can't shift as you
said they just can't shift gears and I
think that one of the best things we can
do for them is remind them why they have
the money in the first place and to make
sure that they can enjoy it and it goes
back to what you were saying about fear
and the markets if people are scared
there that that's a big reason they'll
retain the money we need to be able to
reassure them with very simple
projections of how good a shape their
head and no matter how if the market
pulled back fifty percent here's what
would still happen so they can feel okay
they can have that permission to enjoy
their money hmm thank you for that yeah
what's what what books aside from those
we've mentioned already do you gift the
most to other people or have you gifted
the most other people if any come to
mind they don't they don't have to be
related to investing but they could be
my I think probably the gift the book
I've gifted the most is awareness by
Anthony de Mello he was a a Jesuit
priest but he was in India so he has
kind of this confluence of different
religions from Hindu to Buddhism to
Christianity influencing him but what
the book basically I mean I'm sure I'm
screwing this up and that if he were
alive he'd say I'm explaining it wrong
but to me what it basically said was no
matter how good you think things are
they're not that good no matter how bad
you thinks things are they're not that
bad that almost everything you're
experiencing with other people is about
the other people has very little to do
with you people don't think about you as
much as as you think they do and just a
very I think it's just a very it's a
book that gives you a lot of perspective
about yourself in the world and if you I
think if you read it the right time of
your life for me it brought a lot of
peace I've read the book a few times so
I love that book
I also like it I give to our employees
here the book how full is your bucket
which is like it it might take 15
minutes to read and I don't know if
you've read it but the basically the
premise is the premise is every
encounter you have someone feels better
or they feel worse and what kind of
person are you are are you bringing
positive energy to our into a room are
you the kind of person that are lifting
people up around you or taking them down
even if it's in the most subtle ways and
it just kind of forces some perspective
there's even a children's version of
that I got my kids I absolutely love
that book and then the Prophet by Kahlil
Gibran is is one of my favorite books
someone gifted to that to me when I was
young and it's a short read and and
covers a lot of topics as well that's a
fantastic book I would recommend people
get the edition with the illustrations
by the author also a great yeah if you
get the Prophet let's well I think we're
sort of getting to the tail end of of
this this round one conversation between
you and I but we could we could go in
any number of directions before we we
close out well I thought one might be to
highlight any particular bad advice that
you hear or see being given out often in
your world if if there if there are any
particular red flags or types of bad
advice our tricks that you would you
would advise people to be aware of or
make people aware of I think that I
think that our industry the framework
for the delivery of advice is often
corrupted and so I think the good thing
is when you're educated you can spot it
really easily but if you look at the
industry its unique and that in in the
United States most advisors don't have
to act in their clients best interest
that's fairly unique to the United
States in Australia they have to act on
the clients best interests and the
United Kingdom they have to act on their
clients
Centris it's also unique to financial
advisors diet if you go to a doctor in
the US or a lawyer or CPA they have a
fiduciary obligation act your best
interest but about 90 percent of
advisors in the United States do not
have a fiduciary obligation to their
clients they're operating under a lower
standards of law called the suitability
standard a kind of a buyer beware this
is America everyone fend for yourself
which would be fine except the general
public doesn't know that right they're
assuming when they go to a financial
advisor that the financial advisor is
acting in their best interests all the
time and is legally obligated to do so I
I've never read the law about how my
doctor or lawyer or CPA us to treat me
I'm just assuming that they have to act
in my best interests and that's just not
the case with financial advice so I
think one thing your listeners can watch
for is is my advisor an independent
adviser they would be working for what's
called a are I a registered independent
adviser or are they a broker meaning
they work for a brokerage house that
makes money a lot of different ways on
investments they might make money on a
commission they might own their own
products and so on I think that's one
one way to kind of quickly figure out
does that doesn't mean brokers are bad
there's a lot a lot of brokers doing the
right thing every day for their clients
it's just all things being equal you
would always want somebody who asked to
act in your best interest all the time
who has to do for you what they would do
for themselves I think that's one big
thing to know about the profession I
think the other thing to look out for is
does the adviser get paid different ways
on different investments so if I'm
sitting with somebody and they make more
money if I buy a private equity fund
than a stock fund well don't be
surprised if you wind up being sold the
private equity fund we all know that
compensation drives behavior right so
you don't want somebody who is going to
get paid more if you buy one product
over another that's very common in a
brokerage house but it can even be
something that happens in the
independent world and then you
definitely don't want to be working with
an advisor that has their own their own
products to sell where they might have
their own mutual funds they might have
different names that's kind of a trick
of the trade where you might have a
brokerage house with one name and then
their products are called another name
so it's a little confusing to the client
but if somebody can avoid those things
you know somebody who gets somebody that
stacked in your best interest that gets
paid on your investments the same no
matter what and doesn't own their own
products you are going to avoid a lot of
the things that are going to result in
you not getting the best types of
investment vehicles and then it becomes
all about competence you know and I
think if you want to kind of screen for
confidence I would do it the way you
look for a doctor if you're going to get
knee surgery you want a knee surgeon
that does knee surgery all the time
that's at one of the best hospitals and
has had a lot of thousands of thousands
of people go to them you don't want
somebody that's you know dealing with
just a few people and does knee surgery
every now and then and by the way you
know does 17 other things and is in a
tiny Hospital I think to the extent you
can screen for some level of competence
in scale that's helpful as well gotcha
thank you how do you how do you and
creative planning make money we make
money by charging a fee to our clients
for managing their investments so if
someone comes in and says I want you to
manage a million dollars for us we tell
them the percentage that that's going to
cost and it includes managing their
money and providing them a financial
plan as part of that and we also would
give them all the financial advice they
need throughout the year we would meet
with them in person and we would not
make a different amount of money no
matter what investment they went into so
whether it's appropriate for them to be
an investment ABC alternative or
publicly traded the compensation stays
neutral and we hold our clients money at
third parties so it can don't have to
worry about the custody issue or the
Bernie Madoff issue and then there's no
commitment from the client if anywhere
along the way they feel like oh I want
to go back to doing it myself there
they've got an open door to be able to
do that thank you yeah let's ask us to a
few more questions and then we can close
up for this conversation so the first is
what advice how old are you now if you
don't mind me asking 48 48 what advice
would you give to your 30
your old self and if you could place us
like where you are at 30 what you're
doing or roughly 30 that'd be helpful I
think it at around 30 I was starting to
have some success and I'm a
people-pleaser by Nature and I was
starting to get asked to be on boards by
clients and I just accept all of these
invitations I found myself on all these
boards and you know was I was saying yes
to all kinds of things assistant coach
this and be on this charity and so on
and I wound up being terrible at all of
it and I I learned this later and I wish
I had learned it at age 30 that a yes to
something is a note of something else
right once you are saying yes to
something you're you're saying no to
something else and so it wasn't it
didn't take me too long to get a sense
of priority but when I got it I became
crystal clear to me what my priorities
in life were and it made it much easier
the things I was going to say yes to it
if I had a time machine I would tell
myself that at age thirty a little bit
earlier how do you help clients find
clarity on what to hone in on if they're
if they're looking for it if if you have
clients who are running into the same
issues perhaps since you I would imagine
on one hand you are managing wealth but
on the other hand you're managing lives
and if we're looking at that
holistically you're probably going to be
dealing with many facets of someone's
commitments financial or otherwise so
what what tactical advice would you give
them
if someone's feeling pulled in a
thousand directions they're saying yes
to too many things well I think one of
the advantages that they would have is
we can we are there no often so I know a
lot of them have a hard time saying yes
or no to people that are asking for
money and because let's face it you know
somebody's asking for fifty thousand or
a hundred thousand from from some of our
clients that's not a big deal to that
client but the client doesn't want to
wind up doing a whole bunch of different
things and wind up with a bunch of tax
forms and be all over the place and so
we do two things one we develop rules so
you try to develop criteria so that
instead of every deal that comes to you
your
evaluating the deal you're starting by
saying what types of deals am I willing
to look at right so you're setting
criteria on day 1 or if you're being
asked to do a lot of charitable giving
instead of evaluating every charity that
comes to you let's set criteria of the
types of charities you're willing to
support maybe it's only in a certain
geographic area maybe it only involves
children maybe it's things that a
certain percentage goes back into the
community versus overhead if you set
those rules it becomes easier to say no
to those private investments or to those
charitable donations so then second you
can always use a third party as a screen
right you could always use your advisor
or somebody that works in your office
you know that this person's job is to
evaluate these things against the
principles that we have we have some
clients that have gone so far as to you
know if they're bigger they even will
create a web page that would say you
know this is how the grant-giving works
and so it creates a little bit of work
upfront for the person asking for the
charity which eliminates a lot of stuff
they've got to fill out an application
and explain why and where things are
going and then they they might self
eliminate by seeing that they don't meet
the rules as well and then third they
realize it's not just I'm calling Susan
to see if Susan will give me the money
there's a there's a procedure and it's
not so personal
Susan then comes back and says no that
makes sense what would you put on a
billboard
if metaphorically speaking to get a
message out to millions or billions of
people can't be commercial but a word a
quote question anything at all is there
anything that comes to mind you put on a
billboard I would put is it worth it
on the Billboard I just say is it worth
it so if I was and I put that billboard
right down my streets when I was getting
in the car wherever I was going it would
remind me you know is what I'm doing
right now what I should be doing you
know if I've got us and if my priorities
are family and friends and work is in
there and things like that is what I'm
doing is it is it worth it does it fit
in to what what I'm doing and I think so
many of us we just wind up getting
sucked into all of these things I hate
to be the purse
that quotes Socrates but I have a big
fan of his and he said beware the
Baroness of a busy life right we find
ourselves just doing all of these
different things and if you really stop
and look at your week and say everything
that you did did it really or did it
really align with what you want to be
about and so I'm constantly trying to
remind myself of that I'm constantly
looking at my calendar and asking should
these things be on my calendar you know
it's been said don't tell me what's
important to you I'll look in your
wallet and I'll look at your calendar
and that's all I need to do to know
what's important to you and so I think
any reminder you can have of that
ongoing I think is a positive thing I
agree yeah busyness what a deceptively
problematic characteristic that is to
carry you through your day today
absolutely it carries over to investing
I think people create busyness with
their investments they get caught up in
the news cycle and it doesn't matter if
they watch it they could get all the
news they need probably in 15 minutes
they don't need to watch three hours a
day every day
but they create this busyness and they
create this anxiety and they feed that
that all of that tension that then
creates action in the portfolio that
should never happen because they should
be like you were talking about earlier
just leaving it alone and finding the
discipline to do it but they create this
busyness that creates the anxiety to
make the behavioral mistakes that cause
the problems in the in the first place
so just like with the with life I think
with investing you really got to set
your rules and you and you've got to
have a plan in Mike Tyson who I know and
and I just think he's he's incredibly
smart guy and he's got a famous saying
where he said everyone's got a game plan
until they get punched in the mouth
right and I think if you've got clarity
and vision and you know what you want to
do and you know what your priorities are
with investing you can stick with it
when you get punched in the mouth as
well and so they have busyness and life
I think it's the same thing with
investing here here people can find
creative planning at creative planning
calm they can find you at Peter Mallick
mal L o u K dot-com where is the best
place on social media to say hello or
with you and then these will all be in
the shownotes of course but do you
interact or pay attention to anything
more than another or none of the above
both myself and creative planning are on
LinkedIn Twitter and Facebook and I know
creative planning is paying attention to
all of them all of the time I tend to be
more engaged with LinkedIn and Twitter
personally great all right on Twitter at
Peter Mallick on LinkedIn also Peter -
maluca and I'll link to all of this in
the show notes for people and to
everything that we discussed in this
conversation all the books and any other
people or resources so folks can find
that at tim dot blog forward slash
podcast and it's typed in guest name
maluca mal l o u K or Peter and it will
pop right up is there anything else
Peter that you'd like to say any parting
comments suggestions requests anything
else you'd like to say before we before
we wrap up I would give a parting
comment that I think really would help
people think about and investing better
and I think if we if we can be objective
about where we are in history we are
living at the best time that anyone has
ever lived right I mean the world lived
in abject poverty for thousands and
thousands of years until just a few
centuries ago and if you sit would I sit
with physician clients they'll tell me
there have been more advances with the
brain and the heart in the last 10 or 20
years than all of history before and you
know I don't you were very involved in
the tech world and they would tell you
the same thing there we can go on and on
and if you look at what drives markets
we need consumers to buy things you know
we need the demographics we have over a
billion people coming out of poverty in
the next 10 to 20 years all over the
world in India and China and Brazil and
all over the world so we've got those
consumers coming and they're going to
buy Nikes and they're going to go to
McDonald's and and they're gonna buy
clothes and they're gonna watch movies
we've got those consumers coming and the
other thing that drives markets is
innovation and technology and no
rational person can look at the world
today and think that we're not doing
those things now and so if you look at
the forces that support the markets over
the next 10 20 30 years if you give
those have never been better that
doesn't mean that there aren't gonna be
setbacks and pullbacks but if you can
just no matter with all the negativity
we have coming at us from every
direction the reality is it's never been
better than this and so I think that
that helps me you know just with life in
general I need to remind myself but I
think as an investor it helps you focus
on the long run and maybe tune out
whatever it is that's got you panicking
and and keeping you from doing the right
things for your for the way you should
be investing to get where you need to go
thank you so much Peter for taking the
time I really appreciate it and I've got
lots of notes that I'll be following up
on as well as grabbing a copy of
awareness I'm all for anything that
brings peace especially in these
fear-mongering times that we live in but
I appreciate you taking the time for the
conversation so thank you vomit thanks
for having me Tim and to everybody
listening thank you for tuning in and
you can find the show notes tuned up log
forward slash podcast and until next
time have a plan formulate a plan
whatever it might be
whether it is finances whether it is fat
loss anything else that might be on your
to-do list especially if it has been on
your to-do list for a long period of
time and has been punted from one day or
one week or one month to the next and
then to the next formulate a plan the
resources are out there thanks very much
everybody talk to you next time hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and what you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday if that provides a little morsel
of fun for the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favourite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour workweek com
all spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
LegalZoom which more than 2 million
Americans have used to help start their
businesses past guests even such as well
WordPress lead developer CEO of
automatic Matt Mullenweg now valued at
more than a billion dollars have used
LegalZoom to help with their business
needs specifically in his case to form
his company but LegalZoom isn't just for
launching your business their services
include everything from helping you to
manage changing tax laws reviewing
contracts creating NDA's non-disclosure
agreements important stuff handling
lease agreements and assisting with
really any other legal challenge hurdle
inconvenience that typically takes time
and effort away from running your
business the best part is that you won't
get charged by the hour
because Lille zoom isn't a law firm so
they won't be running the clock up and
spinning circles just to raise your bill
instead they just ask you to pay one low
upfront price for whatever it is that
you're looking to get on a cart style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all of their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T I am at checkout
capital T lower case I am again take
peak legalzoom.com and enter promo code
to him
this episode is brought to you by
99designs 99designs is the global
creative platform that makes it easy for
designers and clients to work together
from logos to apps packaging to books
99designs
is the go-to design resource for any
budget I've used 99 designs for many
many years now I've used them for book
covers for instance mock-ups for the
4-hour body which went on to become a
number one New York Times best seller
illustrations for my multi-volume The
Tao of Seneca and other graphic design
projects and I've been really impressed
by the quality of their designers and
the designs that I've been diffusing
most recently I used 99 designs to
update the illustrations and layouts of
my five morning rituals eBook this
covers my most consistent morning
routines and rituals and I offer that as
an incentive for people to sign up for
my newsletter so this is a PDF bonus
that acts as a carrot to increase the
number of email subscribers the
illustrations inside gorgeous and I
loved working with the designer who we
selected for the project so you can
check it out take a look at that at 99
designs comm forward slash Tim that's
the number 99 designs com forward slash
Tim and you can see exactly what I'm
talking about with a real world example
of what has come out of work with them
nunya and designs designer search tool
connects you directly with one designer
based on a design category or an
industry specialization style skill
level availability and more so you can
really check all the boxes that you need
and see who matches up or you can start
a contest and that means you invite the
entire community to take a shot at your
project then you pick your favorite
right now you guys my listeners that is
can receive a free $99 upgrade on your
first design contest so check it out to
see what it looks like to get your first
free upgrade please visit 99designs
dot-com for Tim and click on the link in
the landing page so again check it out
99designs dot-com forward slash tip
[Music]